my name is Gabriela who I'm an assistant
professor in electrical and computer
engineering department and engineering
public policy department
tation is entitled can we make the great
work better without lots of new
transmission lines so in this figure you
see a graphical representation of the
electric power grid we have the power
stations in which the electric power is
generated we have the customers which
consume the electricity and we have in
the middle of the transmission system
which is the high voltage system and the
distribution system which is the low
voltage system now the transmission
system is a mesh network that means that
power can flow multiple paths so you
could have two parallel paths and part
of the power is flowing over one line
and the rest on with the other line now
challenges which we're encountering is
that well power flows according to
kerkoff's law so physical laws that
means it's given by the line parameters
and where power is injected where the
power is flowing so we can't influence
that very well so that means that when
we have parallel lines again partly
lower one line and the rest will flow
over the other line now that wouldn't be
so bad if we would have unlimited
transfer capacity of each line but each
line is actually limited so the maximum
amount of power that we can transmit is
is limited so let's look at the
simplified version why is that now a
problem that we can't transmit an
unlimited amount of power let's assume
we have these two power stations and we
want to provide electricity to the load
on the bottom now if we start generating
with these two generators at some point
we will reach one of the lines which
will actually leech the rim it if the
power flows according to the arrows that
EC in in the in the figures now let's
assume that the right generation plan is
the one which is providing power at low
cost and the other one is more expensive
so that means that as soon as this line
reaches its limit we can't use the
cheaper Tran jeepers generator anymore
to supply the load or another reason why
we would want to be able to get rid of
this congestion is that this generation
plant might be a wind power plant so if
we can't use that and you
or then we basically have to spill
available wind power which is variable
very valuable so ways how we can solve
that problem is built generation closer
to load so that and we don't need to
transmit it that much anymore or we
build additional transmission lines
which give us additional transfer
capacity another option is to increase
the capacity of already existing lines
or transmission corridors by replacing
transmission lines are also adding
transmission lines another option which
I am I group are working on quite
extensively is controlling how power
flows over over the mesh network now
we're saying at the beginning that
kerkoff's loss define where power is
flowing this is based on the line
parameters so we're able to influence
the line parameters we basically click
an influence or power flows and turn
basically cheat don cucos laws options
how we can do that are flexible AC
transmission systems high-voltage DC
lines storage devices and I'm going to
talk about each of them just in a minute
what they are all able to do is that we
can push some power from one line to to
the parallel system that means that the
power group becomes more flexible which
exactly meets the needs of the future
electric power system with a significant
amount of variable renewable generation
imagine that at some point in time you
have a lot of wind generation in one on
one side of the system and that results
in concessions on that set on that side
you're able to push power to the rest of
the system however if the congestion is
on the other side of the system you're
able to again push some power to the
other side of the system now of course
how much you can push or how much you
can influence the power flow is always
limited and one of the advantage of the
of the different devices that I just
mentioned are that they're still quite
expensive however in my group we're
working on the algorithms on how could
we how do we control these elements if
we have them in the system so we're not
concerned about how do we develop
cost-effective solutions but other
people are working on that
now let's first talk about flexible AC
transmission systems or effects devices
these devices are based on power
electronics and what they're doing is
influencing the line parameter so the
reactance of of a line which which will
dip which will decide how much power
flow is flowing over that line now so if
you're placing that device in the line
which is congested what it allows us to
do is push some power over the payroll
system that means that we can still use
or cheap generator or use increased wind
generation at that location and supply
the load so another device which you can
use to influence power flows or HVDC
lines HVDC lines what that means is you
convert the power at one location into
DC power and then at the end of the line
converted back into AC power or
traditional power system is all based on
AC power that's why we're converting
that into need to convert it into DC
power if we're using that technology now
the advantage of that system or that
technology is that let's say we're
placing that in one of the lines that we
can convert the power or we can decide
how much power we want to convert on
that end of the line and how much we
transmit over that the line again that
will allow us to rear out some power
over the rest of the system so powerful
o is becoming uncontrollable another
method how we can control power flow is
by putting different storage devices at
different locations in the system that
allows us to transmit power when there's
enough transmission capacity and you
stored energy when we when we need it so
again in our little example if you put
the storage devices where you see it now
in the craft we could simply feed into
the storage when we don't have enough
transmission capacity and use what we
have in the in the other storage device
to supply the load so that's also why
how we can influence power flows so
research questions that we're trying to
address is how we should determine the
control settings of the of these
power flow control devices independent
of what device it is so imagine if you
have multiple of these devices in the
system one of them will influence what
how much power is flowing through the
other one and they might start fighting
against each other if you're not
coordinating them so especially if
there's a large amount of these of these
devices in the system it's very
important to coordinate them another
question is what is the objective of the
control do you want to minimize
generation cost you want to Mize
reliability in in the power grid and so
on so generally what we're doing is
we're developing methods which allow us
to do distributed but coordinate the
control that means that we're assigning
a responsibility of the control for a
certain area in the system to to a
certain entity and the idea is that
these entities talk to each other but in
a very limited way but that there is
determining the control settings which
would also be optimal from the
centralized perspective so we want to
achieve the overall optimal settings of
all of these devices which would also
result in a good coordination of these
devices the general objective that we're
looking at is remove improve reliability
and reduce generation costs so having a
trade-off between reliability and
generation cost so that brings me to my
the end of my presentation if you have
questions please feel free to send me an
email